[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today we're going to be
talking about everything you need to
know about the nine magic night captains
and their powers if you want to see more
videos on black clover on this channel
definitely smash that like button to let
me know and leave suggestions in the
comments for what type of video you'd
like to see also if you're new to the
channel smash that subscribe button and
bring that magic youtube Bell so you
don't miss any new videos
there will be manga spoilers in this
video so if you don't want to know
anything beyond where the anime is right
now you've been warned now let's jump
into some magical information I decided
to move from the order of the team with
the lowest stars earned at the latest
annual Star Awards festival and then
move up to the highest ranked team so in
last place with 49 stars earned we got
the azure dere squad with their leader
realm
real is 19 years old and the youngest
person to ever become a magic night
captain real is an absolutely
fascinating and overpowered character
like others as we'll see later as he was
growing up he was viewed as a monster
because of his painting magic that
allows him to generate and control any
element through his painting after he
got his grimoire
he stayed locked up in his room painting
but the paint magic would costly
destroyed the walls of the building he
lived in because of this destruction he
was asked by his Guardians to stop
painting but he refused saying that they
don't understand his paintings or his
pain he seeks to paint a masterpiece and
like an eccentric artist he lives in his
own world paying little attention to the
people around him he caused so much
damage one time that it injures his
Butler Walter and leaves a lasting scar
on his head Walter slaps rill not
because he is angry but so that real
will understand what other people feel
when he hurts them
he asks rill to try to understand others
instead of just resented the fact that
they don't understand him in his art
rather than seeing him as a monster
Walter
his overwhelming talent and suggests
that he joined the magic Knights where
he can wield his magic to the fullest
and eventually paint his masterpiece
according to his Butler the stronger his
opponent is the more creative
inspiration flows through rail so in
other words he becomes stronger
according to the official data book his
stats are as follows two out of five and
physical strength five out of five in
magic amount five out of five in magic
control three out of five in magic
sensing three out of five in cleverness
and of course a five out of five in
creativity now let's look at some
examples of the magic he can do when the
purple orchid captain Gelder tries to
escape Brill is the one who eventually
captures him using his paint magic he
uses a spell called spring of
restriction it's an extremely cool magic
since he can create anything he paints
and according to Walter grills
imagination in creativity are infinite
which would mean his power is as well he
can use transformation magic to which he
uses to secretly enter the Royal Knights
selection exam during this exam reel
shows off more of his insane power in
his first fight he simultaneously
launches a giant fire and a giant ice
attack most majors cannot even launch
two similar types of magic at the same
time like ice and water for instance but
rill effortlessly can launch two strong
magic attacks that take the form of
completely different elements using his
paint magic in his next battle against
Lux team the opposing team combines
their magical power and sends an attack
that would supposedly pierce anything
called Thunder God's arrow but real uses
his painting magic to summon two god of
thunder and send the magic attack right
back at lux team winning the match in
the process this is where the creativity
comes in he didn't simply block the
attack but found a way to make the
overpowered attack his own and send it
back to the opposing team later in the
final against you know rel could match
you know spirit storm attack with his
paint magic and he was getting ready to
take it up a notch when the magic power
coming off of him destroyed his own
team's crystal so they lost to you nose
team even though rails paint magic
itself was not beaten ironically real
lost
because of his overwhelming power I
truly think that reals paint magic
combined with his creativity makes him
one of the most overpowered mages in the
series but let me know who you think is
the most overpowered mage in the
comments below
coming in 8th place we have the purple
orcas with 51 stars when we began the
series the captain of the squad was
Gelder plazo he is an ambitious man who
loves money and status and that blind
ambition leads him to betrayed the
clover kingdom in the data book he
scored a 3 out of 5 in physical strength
a 5 out of 5 in magic amount a 5 out of
5 in magic control a 3 out of 5 in magic
sensing a 4 out of 5 in cleverness and
of course a 5 out of 5 in permeability
Gelder's magic is amazing his magic is
called permeation magic it can make him
invisible and impervious to magic
attacks for a time in addition to that
he can create invisible soldiers to
attack others and Gelder also has a
spell called invisible fellow-travellers
which can make others invisible as well
not only this permeation magic make one
invisible physically it also erases
other people's ability to sense their
magic powers in many ways Gelder seems
like a reference to Plato's Republic and
the tale of the ring of guy geez in the
book a man named glocken argues that
people only act justly because they care
about maintaining their reputation for
virtue and justice he says that if
someone was given the ring of guy geez
which would make the wearer invisible no
man would keep his hands off what was
not his own when he could safely take
what he liked out of the market or go
into houses and lie with anyone at his
pleasure or kill or release from prison
whom he would and in all respects be
like a God among men Gelder is a
textbook example of glycans point since
he got a similar power and abused it to
get ahead unlucky for Gelder though
Ausmus his Achilles heel since he can
sense key and negate magic nonetheless
the tale of Gelder and the ring of guy
jeez make for an interesting thought
experiment of course Gelder gets caught
but the question remains do you think
that glocken is right and that people
would act unjustly to benefit themselves
if they knew they wouldn't be
and could maintain their just reputation
in the eyes of others anyways after
Gellar gets caught kaiser grande vodka
becomes the new captain of the purple
orchid squad aside from his cool hair
and moustache we do not know much about
him his magic powers have not been
revealed for the time being
next up with 67 points we have the coral
peacock squad and their captain Dorothy
Unsworth the woman that is always
sleeping even though she seems to be
asleep most of the time she seems to be
aware of her surroundings at the same
time for instance she voted for you know
at the magic Knights entrance exam and
she keeps up with the other captains
when they're pursuing the fleeing Gelder
so even though she's been around we have
yet to see her magical powers in action
however we do know that she is a witch
from the witch's forest
there's no doubt in my mind that she
will be extremely powerful since she
made it from the witch's forests all the
way to the position of captain and it's
clear at this point that Tabata is
saving her power for a special occasion
so definitely keep your eye on her and
let me know if you have any theories for
what her power might be in sixth place
with 69 points we have the green man to
squad and their leader Jack the Ripper
as the name suggests Jack loved slicing
things up and also licking his magic
blades which sprout from his arms he
uses Semmering magic according to Finn
raw he's a super sadistic destruction
fiend who brags that he'll slice up the
whole world and Finn Ross says that the
green mantis captain supposedly shaved
the whole mountain away in a little
dust-up with the ami although Jack
mentions that he and Yami have some past
grudges it seems that overall they have
a friendly rivalry going on and Jack
wants to beat Yami when Yami is at 100%
in other words when he's at his best
according to the data book Jack stats
are as follows he scored a 4 out of 5
and physical strength a 4 out of 5 in
magic amount a 5 out of 5 in magic
control a 4 out of 5 in magic
saying a 4 out of 5 in cleverness and a
5 out of 5 in being combative against
the villain vetto
he uses his move death scythe which
easily slices through the ground
although he scores lower in magic amount
than some other captains he is able to
do devastating damage because his
control of magic is so good and he can
focus all of the magic he does have and
do precise concentrated slashes jack has
no issues keeping up with meto
and even offers to help know Zell out
when he appears to be having some
trouble against fauna the fire magic
user according to Jack he can adjust his
blades properties to match his enemies
magic so given enough time there's
nothing he can't cut he also has a move
called death scythe insanity tear where
he launches countless quick slashes at
the enemy in addition he's used
reinforcement magic on his legs to
increase his speed in battle let me cut
to the chase he's an interesting
character that's always fun to watch and
it seems like he can go toe-to-toe with
the ami which is no small feat in fifth
place with 76 votes we have the Crimson
lion squad and their captain Fugo Leon
Vermillion I should mention that this
squad usually ranks higher the year
before they came in second overall only
being beaten out by the Golden Dawn
squad but it would seem that the absence
of their captain after he was gravely
injured and sent into a coma has had a
negative impact on the squad's
effectiveness I'm burning up to talk
about this captain because he's one of
my favorite characters he vowed to
become the next wizard King and he
marked himself with a diamond on the
center of his forehead as a sign of that
personal oath the diamond-shaped mark is
passed down specifically in the
Vermilion noble family and it is only
worn by those who are prepared to
conquer themselves and become king it is
also possible as a noble that he seeks
to be the one to obtain the thrones of
both King and wizard king and become
what is called the true king as is
suggested in chapter 36 of the manga he
is the older brother to Leopold and the
younger brother to the also epic meteo
Leona Vermillion
on her later he is also knows L Silva's
rival and has been ever since they were
kids
unlike knows L fugu Leon does not look
down on commoners and treats hasta with
respect
he even treats Nowell better than the
rest of the Silla family does when Noel
was troubled he told her that being weak
is nothing to be ashamed of
staying weak is which is one of the best
quotes in the series in the data book he
scored four out of five in physical
strength a five out of five in magic
amount a five out of five in magic
control a four out of five in magic
sensing a 5 out of 5 in cleverness and a
5 out of 5 in sense of justice now let's
get into his fire magic like Jack the
Ripper foo go Leon has great control of
magic and can concentrate it to increase
its power his moves soul lenio which is
Latin for Sunline creates a small
sun-like orb of concentrated fire magic
and then shoots a precise concentrated
beam of fire at the target he uses this
spell to break through an odd espiritu's
barrier by the way I just noticed that
Gelder Rebbe she and Radice are all from
purple Orca it looks like the purple
orcas are definitely the Slytherin of
black clovers since there is like a 50%
chance that they'll end up as villains
back to foo go Leon he can also create a
lion made of fire magic and ride it
another attack called lion roaring in
Latin has the giant line shoot a stream
of fire at the enemy this attack can
take out multiple opponents at once the
magical equivalent to a flamethrower he
can also use defensive fire magic Ignace
columnar or fire column is a spell that
surrounds and protects Fugo Leon with
spiraling flames now if that wasn't
enough awesomeness for you
when Fugo leon wakes up from his coma he
is stronger than ever and has somehow
inherited the fire spirit salamander
from fauna which drastically increases
his power also he now has an arm made of
fire magic where his old are used to be
he uses flame spirit magic called
salamanders breath to effortlessly
defeat an elf that Leopold was losing to
of course foo goalie
also can restrain enemies using binding
magic the spell Palma or Lion pom traps
enemies by surrounding them with giant
palms made of fire magic
he was only defeated easily earlier on
because he was tricked by the enemy but
now he's stronger than ever before
overall fugu Leone is definitely one of
my favourite characters and I thought
that even before he had salamander by
his side we can definitely expect great
things from him in the future especially
as salamander continues to evolve with
him next let's talk about the lady who
was acting captain of the Crimson lions
while Fugo Leone was and his coma of
course I'm referring to the uncrowned
undefeated lioness herself meteo Leona
and I will call her Leo enough for short
from here on out to keep things simple
she is another one of my favorite
characters in fact I think all of the
fire using Vermillion czar awesome
including Fugo Leone Leona and Leopold
apparently the royal capital has a
strict wildlife policy and they left
meat out of their diets so for over 300
days a year Leona would go out into the
forest and live in the wild as a country
bumpkin and chow down on that precious
meat because she masked so much in
nature's mana her mana skins
strengthened more than that of other
people although she was strong enough to
be a captain she didn't want to be but
when Fugo Lian is put out of commission
she puts her resistance aside and steps
up to the task
notably she was trained by a ca Silva
growing up aka Noelle's mother but she
could never beat her despite fire having
an elemental advantage over essays
mercury magic that goes to show how
strong Noelle's mother was although we
have to also acknowledge that Leona is
probably a lot stronger now than she was
back then like her brothers
Leona does not respect people because of
their social status rather she respects
people because of their strength
according to the data book her stats are
very similar to forego Leon's except she
actually beat him out in physical
strength getting a perfect 5 out of 5
instead of
out of five her remaining stats are as
follows five out of five in magic amount
five out of five in magic control a four
out of five in magic sensing a 4 out of
5 in cleverness and a five out of five
encourage the only place that foo goalie
on scored better than her was an extra
point on cleverness what is really crazy
is how the lioness completely overpowers
pre transformation Raya and his Opie
imitation magic with her own fire magic
something that Yami or Charlotte did not
succeed in doing even though they also
exchanged attacks with him lalana uses
her fire magic powers to increase her
already insane physical strength for
instance she has a move that is Latin
for fiery arm where she surrounds her
arm with her fiery aura and sends
consecutive punches at her opponent who
bursts into flames Raya seems powerless
against this attack aside from already
having a vast amount of magic the
lioness is amazing.i using mana in the
surrounding area to increase all of her
abilities including her attacks she uses
this ability to enhance her fiery arm
attack she can also take it up a notch
with her spell mana zone full power
Kalidas brock 'i'm purgatory where she
surrounds the whole area with her fire
magic attack this woman is able to take
on five elves by herself for a
substantial amount of time one of them
being an empowered Raya and a
brainwashed and empowered gril whose
Opie magic has already been mentioned
the file of them don't even succeed in
taking her out before Zora and hasta
come back to rescue her the amount of
epicness that metal leona brings to the
story cannot be put into words in my
view her battle with Raya and the 5
elves was the most epic display I've
seen so far in the manga can't wait to
see more of her in the future let me
know why your favorite or most epic
moment in the series was so far next up
in fourth place with 83 stars we have
the blue rose squad and their captain
Charlotte Rosalie Charlotte is a
noblewoman and her backstory is very
of Sleeping Beauty which was also called
little Briar Rose she was cursed when
she reached the age of 18 the curse
would activate trapping her and the
Rosel a noble family within a cage of
time when the curse does eventually
activate her Briar Magic goes out of
control and search growing and spreading
until the whole village is in danger of
being engulfed by the briars Charlotte
is about to give up when our boy Yami
comes to the rescue he explains that her
power spilled the soup he was eating and
asks what she's gonna do about his
spilled soup then Yami says he likes
tough girls but also says that she could
ask for help once in a while and in that
moment the curse is broken and the Briar
Magic reverses apparently the curse was
broken because Yami stole Charlotte's
heart and she secretly liked him ever
since
well disliking most other men in the
data book
Charlotte scored a four out of five in
physical strength a five out of five in
magic amount a five out of five in magic
control a three out of five in magic
sensing a 4 out of 5 in cleverness and a
big fat zero in honesty of course she
uses Bryer magic she has a handle of a
sword and briars come rushing out of it
and she can manipulate them at her well
she can use a move called corpse hunting
briar trees that can capture countless
enemies at a time by trapping them
within her briars Tabitha has also said
that she is the most beautiful woman in
the world of black clover so it's that
much more impressive that our boy Yami
is her prince charming
now we've made it to the top three with
95 stars we have the silver eagle squad
and their captain knows el Silva he is a
nobleman and at times it seems like his
noble status and his cool hair get to
his head
he does look down on commoners and
believes that his nobility makes him
superior to them although he can often
be a jerk to others including hasta and
his own sister Noel he does have some
redeeming qualities for instance even
though he is rivals with Peugeot Leon
and often clashes with him he also has
great respect for him when his brother
insults
go Leone for not being able to deal with
the enemy no Zell says that they should
be even more ashamed than him because
they were not even present for the fight
he then promises to get revenge and make
Fugo Leon's attack or pay for me this
was definitely one of those Elle's best
moments and it was all the more
rewarding because he is usually a jerk
towards people so this little moment
where he shows how upset he is over what
happened to foo go Leon really stuck
with me according to the data book no
zel stats are as follows he got a 4 out
of 5 in physical strength a 5 out of 5
in magic amount of 5 out of 5 in magic
control a 4 out of 5 in magic sensing a
4 out of 5 in cleverness and of course a
5 out of 5 in coolness even if he does
have his servants do his hair every
morning you can't deny that it still
looks really cool no cell uses mercury
magic like the kind his mother had while
his other siblings including Noel all
used water magic one of those cells fare
most use is silver rain wear drops of
mercury rain down at his opponent's it
can be very effective for taking out
large amounts of opponents like when he
used it to tear holes through radishes
attacking corpses knows L can pretty
much manipulate his mercury and have it
take any shape he wants when he comes
with Charlotte and Jack to save Yami
from the third eye he launches an attack
where his mercury takes the form of a
flying spear
he has also created a flying silver
eagle in the past using his mercury
magic and multiple people could ride on
top of it and he has also used the power
to create shields to block attacks one
of the best things about mercury magic
is that it can be quickly manipulated so
that a skilled user can quickly switch
from defense to offense since the
mercury that was used to make shields
for example can quickly be broken down
into its liquid form and quickly sent at
the enemy in the form of a reharden
offensive weapon it definitely is a very
cool power next the squad that surprised
everyone since they got last place last
year and managed to climb all the way to
second place with 101 stars this year of
course I am referring to
to the black balls and we're gonna be
talking about Yami they're awesome
captain Yami is born in the Land of the
Rising Sun in other words the Japan of
the black clover world as a kid one day
he is fishing and he gets shipwrecked
and ends up on the shores of the black
clover Kingdom Yami is discriminated
against because he's of a different race
than everyone else and then later he is
further hated and feared when he
receives his grimoire because of its
unorthodox dark magic it is interesting
that despite not being from the clover
kingdom he gets picked by a clover
grimoire as if he was always meant to
end up there despite most people
discriminating against them Julius the
Future wizard king takes a liking to him
and teaches him how to read and write in
the clover kingdom language he and
William van Jets both joined Julius's
Azur deer squad later Julius becomes the
wizard King and makes William the
captain of Golden Dawn and Yami the
captain of the black bulls despite the
fact that most of the nobles are against
getting such an important position to a
foreign commoner Julius believed in Yami
and ever since Yami has been trying to
make Julius proud and prove to everyone
else that the wizard king made the right
decision about him as a result even
though Yami doesn't seem to take things
seriously most of the time he is serious
when it comes to carrying out Julius's
orders so serious in fact that it
sometimes freaks out his squad according
to the data book Yami got a 5 out of 5
and physical strength a 5 out of 5 in
magic amount a 4 out of 5 in magic
control a 4 out of 5 in magic sensing a
4 out of 5 in cleverness and a perfect 5
out of 5 in limits surpassing as I
mentioned previously Yami uses dark
magic the drawback of dark magic is that
it is generally slow but Yami has found
a way to work around this weakness by
channeling the dark magic into a katana
a type of sword from his homeland he has
multiple moves that he uses over the
course of the story one move is dark
cloaked lightless slash where he slashes
in the direction of the enemy and a wave
of Darkness is released from the sword
and travels through the air in the
direction of his target his move black
hole creates an or
darkness it can draw in an enemy attack
and also temporarily paralyze the user
of the attack if they are in contact
with their spell before he used the
spell in combination with the spell
they're cloaked black blade which uses
darkness to extend the reach of the
user's sword with the spell black cocoon
Yami creates a sphere of dark magic that
can block an enemy's magic attacks
unless they're extraordinary powerful
like Patrese spell ray of divine
punishment in general though darkness is
lights elemental weakness in the world
of black clover like other captains Yami
can use his dark magic to provide a mana
skin for himself thereby increasing his
physical abilities and he can also use
his magic to restrain his enemies his
detection of ki a constant originating
from his homeland is also useful in
battle since it can help him react
quicker in combat and it comes in handy
in cases where mages have a way of
masking their magic powers like Gelder
does currently Yami's strongest spell is
dark clothes dimension slash this attack
as the name suggests can cut through
dimensions notably it is able to cut
through spatial magic which in most
cases should not be possible Yami used
this attack to escape from an enemy's
spatial magic spell called different
dimensions sphere which was supposed to
be impossible to escape from but as we
know by now impossible is nothing
compared to Yami's ability to surpass
his limits even before he got this opie
spell Balto's wondered if Yami's power
could rival the wizard kings when he saw
him fighting Patri so I think it's safe
to say that Yami is already one of the
strongest characters in the series and
no doubt his ability to surpass his
limits will ensure that he keeps getting
stronger in that first place with 125
stars earned we got the golden dawn
squad and their mysterious mask captain
william van gence although i will note
that when the black bulls are at
negative 30 stars early in the series
the golden dawn squad has 100 more than
them putting them at 70 stars at that
point this means that in the time
between then and the award ceremony
Golden Dawn earned 55 stars and the
black balls earned 103
one stars so since Auster join the black
bulls have actually been doing way
better than Golden Dawn which is
something to think about anyways back to
William in Chapter two of the manga it
was stated that William is the man
closest to becoming the next Wizard king
he was the illegitimate child of a noble
and was also discriminated against
because he was born with a giant scar
that covered the top half of his head he
was called a cursed child and people
around him thought he was creepy and
were afraid of him until he was eight he
lived in the forsaken realm but then the
noble lost his heir and so his father
took him back because he had strong
magical powers and his world tree magic
he was viewed as a curiosity yet the
noble still hated his face and his
foster mother the lawful wife of the
father badly abused the young William
however William ed Julius who was amazed
by his magic and wanted him to join the
magic Knights William fear they could
not be a magic knight because of his
scarred face Julius assured him that
it's nothing to worry about but since he
did see that it bothered William he gave
him a mask that he wears to this day
William thought the mask was tacky but
he was happy that someone finally looked
past his scar and was so kind to him so
he pledged his grimoire to Julius's
service so in a way he has a similar
backstory to Yami according to the data
book Williams scored a three out of five
in physical strength a five out of five
in magic amount a five out of five in
magic control a four out of five in
magic sensing a four out of five in
cleverness and a 5 out of 5 in charisma
which explains why he makes such a great
leader he uses world tree magic his
spell magic tree descent has roots of a
tree form in the air and those roots can
be manipulated and made to produce
different wooden objects like
broomsticks his most impressive spell
we've seen to date is great mistltein
tree at first william spreads roots over
a large area then absorbs mana from the
area once enough mana has been absorbed
william creates a giant tree that can
capture many enemies at once another
spell has him simply throw a small seed
at the enemy which quickly grows into a
large tree around the target totally
taking them out of
mission now since we're talking about
William I'm going to reveal the biggest
secret there is to reveal about him so
if you haven't read the manga and you
don't want to know his biggest secret
click away now okay now that it is only
us I feel that it is only right to
mention Patri as well although he is not
a captain he has lived in Williams body
since William was 16 Patri is an elf who
died long ago but was reincarnated into
Williams body when he takes over
Williams body Williams curse disappears
and Patri has the appearance of his
childhood friend lik who was the leader
of the elves using Lix name he becomes
the leader of the Midnight Sun a group
that is trying to resurrect all of the
elves who were supposedly killed by
humans many years ago their goal is to
get revenge on all humans
Patri gets his own grimoire which is why
it is difficult for anyone to figure out
that Patri and William reside the same
body because they use different types of
magic Patri has a very rare kind of
magic it is said that only a few people
have had the ability to use light magic
and Patri is one of them he scored a
four out of five and physical strength a
five out of five in magic amount a five
out of five in magic control a four out
of five in magic sensing a four out of
five and cleverness and a five out of
five in leadership he can use his magic
to move at remarkable speeds the speed
of light is very fast after all he can
also use both offensive magic and
healing magic which is rare he has
amazing Opie attacks like light shaft of
divine punishment that Yami doesn't even
know how to deal with also his spell
arrows of judgment can easily kill an
entire city he creates countless swords
using light magic and sends them
shooting down at the city it is this
move that defeated the wizard king since
the wizard king had to save the people
which cost him his mana and distracted
him allowing Patri to get the finishing
blow on him of course if all that wasn't
enough Patri can also use reincarnation
magic a forbidden form of magic to
revive the souls of the dead and that is
it for today's video all of the magic
night captains and their magical powers
explained wow this that
took a while and it will probably end up
being one of my longest videos but it
was a lot of fun learning about all
these captains and their cool powers and
being able to share my thoughts about
them if you watch all the way to the end
let me know by telling me who your
favorite captain is in the comment if
you enjoyed this video give it a like
and subscribe and ring that magic
youtube bell if you don't want to miss
more black clover content leave
suggestions for future videos you really
want to see in the comments also come
chill with us on Twitch where we stream
regularly you can find us at twitch.tv
slash anime uproar and I'll put a link
in the description anyways until next
time see ya space cowboy
[Music]
you